bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat finalement la tentative
d'audition des directeurs du
renseignement par le sénat aura tourné
court
ni bernard squarcini frédéric péchenard
ne seront entendus par la commission
sénatoriales à d'application des lois
dirigé par le socialiste david assouline
vendredi le gouvernement s'est fermement
opposé à ces auditions
les ministres claude guéant et gérard
longuet ont en effet expliqué que ces
fonctionnaires n'avaient pas de
responsabilité en matière d'évaluation
des lois et qu'il était tenu à un strict
devoir de réserve en cette période
électorale françois fillon a même
qualifié ces auditions d'illégal alors
ici à gauche au sénat on a protesté
contre la décision du gouvernement david
assouline a invoqué l'unité nationale
lorsqu'il s'agit de lutte contre le
terrorisme
ils organisent cependant ce matin une
table ronde en compagnie d'experts en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
l'objectif de cette table ronde qui a
été il faut le noter boycotté par les
sénateurs ump et centristes
et bien c'est de faire un état des lieux
de l'arsenal législatif existant en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
je vous propose donc de voir tout de
suite cette table ronde bonne matinée à
tous
on va commencer donc c'est à travers
cette table ronde c'est le lancement
d'un programme de travail de la
commission sénatoriale de contrôle de
l'application des lois sur un sujet tout
à fait important qui que nous avons été
conduits à choisir à partir bien entendu
de l'actualité dramatique mais qui n'a
pas pour objet de répondre à cette
actualité immédiate ou d'interférer dans
l' enquête dans l'établissement des
faits tels qu'ils se sont produits
nous avons au contraire parce qu'il ya
eu c'est fait et qu'un débat public
s'est engagé sur les dispositifs
législatifs concernant la sécurité
intérieure et la lutte contre le
terrorisme en particulier qui ont pris
un écho parce que le président de la
république a même voulu et demandé qu'un
projet de loi soit déposé au conseil des
ministres dans quelques jours faisant
évoluer la législation
notre commission et est donc
complètement dans son coeur de mission
de dire si on réfléchit sur l'évolution
de la législation il faut d'abord savoir
ce qui existe déjà bien repéré parce que
c'est un ensemble de lois une quinzaine
de loi à travers absolument la décennie
tout ce qui existe
ça apprécié des débats qui ont amené à
ces évolutions législatives régulière
pour pas chaque fois quand on a un
nouveau débat penser qu'on a inventé
l'eau chaude en redisant ce qui a été
dit avant et puis déterminer si c'est
l'évolution laquelle si c'est pas des
évolutions mais démodé des questions de
moyens ou des questions d'organisation
en tous les cas la représentation
parlementaire notre commission était
dans son corps de mission de venir
apporter un diagnostic partagé à ce
débat public et à l'éventualité d'une
évolution des législations pour pour les
pouvoirs publics et pour la reprise et
pour le parlement en général voilà j'ai
voulu que nous auditionnons l'ensemble
des fonctionnaires des acteurs de l'état
qui sont directement impliqués dans
l'application des lois existantes parce
qu'ils savent si c'est suffisant pour
eux si c'est parfois handicap enfin ils
peuvent nous parler en connaissance de
cause
j'ai voulu aussi à travers la table
ronde qui va commencer faire qu'un
certain nombre de ce couvent a appelé
aujourd'hui les experts
et chacun est dans son domaine de
compétences nous puissions avoir un
débat global sur cette question à
travers les compétences de chacun qui
qu'ils soient pas directement un débat
de praticiens de l'état pour lutter
contre le terrorisme et plus d'analystes
de et
et de personnalités d'intellectuels qui
ont réfléchi qui réfléchit sur cette
question je veux doublement les
remercier d'avoir très rapidement
accepté de participer à ces tableaux où
les remercier comme je l'aurais fait si
tout s'était passé que je le souhaitais
parce que voilà où on est disponible et
vous allez vraiment nous aider à cette
réflexion je veux les remercier une
deuxième fois parce que je sais la
difficulté vu la polémique qui s'est
engagé et que je ne voulais pas que nous
ne voulions pas je sais la difficulté de
ne pas vouloir avoir l'impression de
rentrer dans quelque chose qui est un
conflit en apparence entre les uns ou
les autres
je vous parle comme président de la
commission le président d'une
institution est pas comme responsable
tel ou tel bord politique et c'est
l'institution qui vous a invité c'est
devant cette institution vous parler et
je vous remercie d'avoir maintenu et
d'avoir accepté de faire ce que vous
aviez décidé de faire vous aider à la
réflexion
donc on va pas je ne vais pas être blond
parce que l'ensemble des sujets est ce
coup là où leur a transmis un
questionnaire non bon au moins
moralement téléphone vous avez vous a
dit de quoi on va parler bon 2,96 à 2001
la france n'a pas connu un seul mort
liée au terrorisme sur notre territoire
la situation y est tragiquement de
changer la menace terroriste est elle
réelle et nouvelle pour notre pays
est ce que je le dis à partir d'un
rapport que j'ai lu qu'ils avaient faits
julien dray un autre député qui disait
l'évaluation des lois sur
le terrorisme nous semble sur
l'application des lois où je me correct
desai en 2008 les lois sont appliquées
semble efficace et en même temps cette
longue période sans acte terroriste
interrogés les rapporteurs sur le fait
que pas confrontés à la réalité d'un
acte dans les dernières
période nous interroger sur le reste les
dispositifs sur les quoi est ce qu'on
est
est ce que c'est a suffisamment remis en
question pour être adapté à des
nouvelles formes de terrorisme ou mettre
en avant sur ce qui se passe de
réflexion la coopération internationale
et européenne en particulier s'est elle
améliorée fonctionne tel est ce que les
législations et l'harmonie de 2-2-2 des
moyens des outils législatifs conte à
travers l'europe permettent l'efficacité
pensez vous que la pénalisation de la
consultation de sites faisant l'apologie
du terrorisme qui appellent à la haine
et à la violence puisque c'est une des
mesures qui pourraient être proposées
prochainement soient bonnes mesures au
sens de l'efficacité
vous pensez vous qu'à lille que c'est
possible que c'est souhaitable
comment évaluez vous la législation sur
le terrorisme la sécurité intérieure
actuelle sur le plan préventif et sur le
plan répressif et je veux finir en vous
posant la question parce que certains
d'entre vous une flexion là dessus aussi
sûr parce qu'il s'agit pas non plus de
n'importe quelle menace terroriste
aujourd'hui globalement quelle quelle
appréciation faites vous de deux
situations différentes qui peuvent avoir
des connexions la force du prosélytisme
dans un certain nombre de territoires en
france que pas prosélytisme en général
mais avec des organisations ou des
prêches ou d endoctrinement assez
radicaux de propos appelant à la haine
avec ensuite des possibilités de passage
à l'acte
comment vous appréciez les liens qui
peuvent se faire est ce que c'est
quelque chose d'épique phénoménal qui
sont sept produits dans cette situation
ou qui peuvent être plus peu un vrai
danger plus haut et pensez vous que le
la législation qui combat l'incitation à
la haine et l'appel au meurtre notamment
par les mots et suffisamment est
suffisante et suffisamment appliquée je
le dis notamment en lien avec le fait
que était notamment à la polémique sur
les prédicateurs qui devait venir réduit
iev et qui appellent clairement quand
même pour certains d'entre eux à la
haine raciale voire même à la
suppression de 2 de certaines personnes
sur notre planète et qui voit là était
déjà venu parler dans les mêmes
conditions d'apparemment ou leur
interdit de devenir les pouvoirs publics
ne souhaite pas qu'ils viennent mais
l'incidence entre la possibilité
d'émettre de tels propos et la
traduction sur le terrain ensuite sur
aws et des jeunes qui peuvent être
fragiles et sont parés de tels propos
alors jean pierre sueur on veut aussi
dire un petit mot et ensuite je vous
proposerai l'organisation suivante c'est
que chacun vous ayez un propos liminaire
global de peut être entre 10 minutes et
un quart d'heure et que à l'issue de
vous exposer
sénateurs présents puissent vous posez
des questions qu'ils souhaitent voir
monsieur monsieur merci david je voulais
remercier david assouline d'avoir bien
voulu m'inviter à la à cette réunion en
tant que président de la commission des
lois
je voulais dire que la démarche que
votre commission a initié à l'initiative
de son président e est une démarche très
importante dans la mesure bien sûr où
elle est encadrée sur un objet très
précis et moi ce qui me paraît le plus
important peut aujourd'hui que la digue
mais je me permets de le redire et c'est
la question filante
tout le monde a été horrifiée de ce qui
s'est passé à toulouse et à montauban il
y à beaucoup d'interrogations
aujourd'hui sur ce qui s'est passé on a
tous rendu hommage aux policiers aux
militaires qui ont le vrai dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
cela cet hommage que nous avons rendu
n'empêche pas de se poser des questions
dans une démocratie est la seule
question
enfin la question principale qui me
paraît justifié toutes les auditions que
nous allons procéder la suivante est ce
que les lois existantes en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme vous
paraissent suffisantes
est ce qu'elles ont été appliquées
correctement
est ce qu'il y ait eu des défauts dans
l'application de ces lois
ou est ce que vous pensez qu'on aurait
pu tirer un parti de ces lois différends
de manière à prévenir ce qui s'est passé
donc je pose ces questions très
directement parce que il me semble que
c'est l'objet avant de faire de
nouvelles lois il est sage et c'est le
travail que tu as accompli que vous
accomplissez semaine après semaine
d'évaluer si les lois existantes sont
utiles sont appliqués sont bien
appliquées donc la question est celle là
pour moi
comment quelle appréciation portez vous
sur les lois existantes par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé sur la manière dont
elles ont été appliquées ou n'ont pas
été appliqués et ceci étant dit sans
j'assiste là dessus je les dis au début
porter quelques atteinte que ce soit aux
personnes
bon si on avait été là en obligation de
prendre des décisions
le matin à 11h du et à prendre des
décisions dans les secondes dans les
minutes
personne ne va porter la pierre à
personne c'est ce serait vraiment
indécent c'est clair mais en même temps
il est légitime de savoir ce que vous
pensez de des lois de l'application de
navigation d'eloise istanbul merci jean
pierre sueur donc président de la
commission des lois et dont la présence
est importante
ce matin avec nous est-ce que gg 1 j'ai
un ordre
est-ce qu'il va vous convenir monsieur
samir amghar vous commencez alors on
avait dit que vous vous présenter à
chaque fois je comme ça j'ai pas besoin
de le faire à peu près d'accord si vous
préférez je vous présente à chaque fois
voilà c'est parce que ça permet en plus
de gens vous présentant de de données
déjà d'abord exactement alors je suis
samir amghar je suis docteur en
sociologie de l'école des hautes études
en sciences sociales et spécialiste de
l'islam contemporain et à ce titre j'ai
réalisé un certain nombre de terrains
portant sur les différents sur les
courants de l'islam militant en
interviewant des responsables religieux
en europe en afrique du nord mais
également au moyen-orient et c'est dans
ce cadre que j'ai réalisé deux ouvrages
qui sont parus récemment
le premier est issu de ma thèse de
doctorat qui porte sur le salafisme
d'aujourd'hui mouvements sectaires en
occident qui est une étude qui parle du
principe fin de l'hypothèse centrale en
fin de mon une hypothèse que le mode de
socialisation dans les milieux
salafistes en occident et plus
particulièrement en france est de nature
sectaire au sens où les sociologues des
religions d'entente j'ai fait paraître
également un ouvrage récemment aux
éditions michalon qui s'appelle les
islamistes aux défis du pouvoir et dans
cet ouvrage essaie de montrer comment
les islamistes ou maghrébine également
moyen-orient se repositionne d'un point
de vue idéologique lorsqu'ils sont à la
perspective d' exercer le pouvoir
alors mon intervention va ici se
concentrer sur essayer de faire quelque
part une sorte d'état des lieux de bilan
assez générale du jihadisme en france
alors mon intervention va s'articuler
vous m'entendez alors mon intervention
va s'articuler autour de deux points
s'agira dans un premier temps de vous
montrer dans quelle mesure on assiste à
l'essoufflement du djihadisme autrement
dit depuis quelques années on constate
que les théoriciens du djihad les
militants du djihad sont en crise ont du
mal à recruter
dans un deuxième temps j'essaierai de
vous montrer que face à cette crise les
théoriciens jihad les militants du
djihad ceux qui gravitent autour de
leaders charismatiques qui appelle au
djihad réinvente des nouvelles formes
d'engagement au nom du djihad
alors ce qui est très important d'avoir
à l'esprit c'est que l'itinéraire de
mohamed merah est un itinéraire
exceptionnel
bien qu'il ait lustre de manière
exemplaire le destin de quelques jeunes
de la même génération issus de
l'immigration musulmane et qui ont
décidé de faire ou d'entrer dans le
giron
alors c'est une personne qui est issu
d'une famille des structures et qui est
connu pour avoir séjourné en prison qui
a prétendu fréquenté les milieux
jihadistes par de nombreux séjours
en afghanistan où ils auraient été en
contact avec eux
des responsables d'al qaïda où il aurait
également suivi une formation militaire
alors cet itinéraire traditionnel
quelque part ne doit pas masquer les
difficultés que connaissent actuellement
depuis quelques années le jihad en
france et en occident alors les
spécialistes de l'islam contemporain
s'accordent tous pour dire que le djihad
connaît ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
essoufflement alors quand je dis
essoufflement je ne dis pas déclare je
ne dis pas disparition mais difficulté
pour les djihadistes de commettre des
actes terroristes et en même temps de
recruter alors cette crise s'organise où
se manifeste à travers de logique
une première logique et quelque part la
crise si vous voulez du grand récit du
jihad global et ensuite une sorte de ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier de fatigue
militants du djihadiste
alors lorsque je parle de crise du
modèle jihad comme changement de
politique
c'est l'idée selon laquelle le modèle
prôné par les théoriciens du djihad
notamment d'après d'un qui promettait un
changement global des sociétés
musulmanes via la lutte armée n'a pas
fonctionné alors il parti d'une idée
très simple il s'agissait de commettre à
la fois des attentats dans les pays
musulmans mais également dans les pays
occidentaux pour accélérer le processus
d'islamisation des sociétés musulmanes
pour créer ensuite un état islamique
dans les pays musulmans et au jour
d'aujourd'hui on constate que si des
gouvernements islamistes sont au pouvoir
si des régimes autoritaires dans les
pays arabes sont tombés ce n'est pas à
la suite d'une lutte armée mais plutôt à
la suite d'un long processus on va dire
démocratique produit d'une révolution on
va dire pacifique et à la suite de
succès électoraux des islamistes
donc vous imaginez bien que dans ce cas
la rhétorique jihadiste a du mal à
convaincre
d'autant plus qu'après une décennie dont
on va dire de plein de promesses faites
par les djihadistes en termes de
changement social changements politiques
changement économique et création
d'états islamiques dans les pays
musulmans
force est de constater que ces promesses
du point de vue des militants s'avère
fortement décevant en france on voit un
certain nombre de djihadistes qui ont
connu des débris zay dit l'ours est
emprisonné et donc vous imaginez bien
que dans ce cas là de nombreuses
personnes de nombreuses personnes qui
seraient séduits par la rhétorique jadis
tu réfléchisses à plusieurs fois avant
de s'engager dans le jihad est donc en
ce cas on s'aperçoit que la base
s'étiole les gens sont déçus
fatigué et le recrutement devient de
plus en plus difficile alors s'il ya une
dizaine d'années quelques jeunes de
confession musulmane habite en europe
était attiré par le jihad force est de
constater que le gead au jour
d'aujourd'hui de mais ne bénéficie plus
du même attrait alors c'était
soufflement cette crise du djihad est
également imputable à la surveillance
accrue des services de renseignement en
france qui contrairement à la décennie
des années 90 où il était alors toute
proportion gardée relativement facile de
commettre un attentat
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui il
est impossible quasiment impossible de
commettre un attentat en france sans se
faire immédiatement inquiété et le
démantèlement de nombreuses filières
jihadistes ont de plus considérablement
affaibli la capacité des djihadistes
dont seulement à recruter mais à dents à
à commettre des attentats alors dans ce
cadre pour répondre à cette crise on va
s'apercevoir on va constater que les
djihadistes ou vont réinventer des
nouvelles formes de militance jihadistes
alors celles ci vont ce va s'exprimer on
va dire c'est une nouvelle forme vont
s'exprimer principalement par internet
alors cette crise en matière de jia nan
terme d'essoufflement militants et en
termes d'essoufflement et de logis
contraste énormément avec le
développement relativement important des
sites internet faisant la promotion du
génial alors j'ai fait un inventaire
assez rapide de ce qu'on pouvait trouver
sur internet et j'ai constaté qu' il y
avait à peu près une dizaine de sites et
trois forums de discussion en langue
anglaise
seize sites et six forums de discussion
en français alors il faut bien avoir à
l'esprit que ces sites internet n'ont
pas pour objectif de recruter de futurs
militants mais plutôt essayer de
maintenir dans l'esprit des personnes
qui surf sur internet
l'emblème du jihad dans l'esprit et dans
la toile l'objectif quelque part c'est
de compenser ses difficultés
d'un point de vue concret dans le réel
en ne compensant et en saveurs
abaissement sur investissement
excusez-moi de la militance du
militantisme dans sur internet
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que ces sites sont très visités et on
comptabilise chaque jour plusieurs
centaines d'individus qui se rend sur
ces sites
alors ces sites choses très
intéressantes peuvent également en plus
d'apparaître comme un moyen de maintenir
l'emblème du djihad sur la toile est
également un lieu pour soutenir et aider
des personnes en prison est emprisonné
des anciens jihadistes qui sont en
prison condamné à des peines de prison
et à partir de ces sites on va organiser
des quêtes qui auront pour but d'aider
tel ou tel jihadistes pour payer les
frais d'avocat ou diffuser des
informations quant à là haut degré ou à
la manière dont le procès se déroule
alors à côté de ceux ci bergia de ce gie
est virtuel on va s'apercevoir que de
plus en plus de krupp skull vont
s'inscrire en france dans la rhétorique
djihadistes vont se réclamer d'un taille
da vont s'inscrire dans la filiation
doctrinal d'al qaïda
considérant que le discours ou
l'étonnant d'al qaïda sont des
théologiens qu'il faut absolument suivre
et y mettez dans leurs comptes
fortement et chose qui est très
intéressante c'est que ces groupuscules
ne vont pas opté pour l'action violente
l'action terroriste le jihad et vont
considérer que le gia ne doit pas
s'exprimer à travers des logiques armée
mais plutôt par rapport à des logiques
d'agitation et de propagande on va
s'organiser on va organiser une
manifestation où on va brûler par
exemple le code pénal en expliquant que
le code pénal est à code qui légifèrent
non pas au nom de la foi religieuse au
nom du coran n'est au nom de lois qui
sont étrangères aux lois coraniques
on va par exemple manifesté autour d'une
mosquée parce qu'on n'est pas du tout
d'accord avec l'option théologique que
l'imam qui j'ai qui gérent cette mosquée
prend et donc on va voir que
régulièrement des groupuscules vont
s'organiser on va dire selon cette
logique là vont s'inscrire dans cette
logique du jeune mais quelque part vont
faire le bilan critique de toutes ces
années de combat ou de lutte armée en
disant qu'effectivement ça a été
peut-être efficace dans une certaine
mesure mais qu'il est nécessaire compte
tenu du contexte dans lequel on se
trouve
redéfinir le jihad et opter pour ce
qu'on pourrait appeler de l'agitation de
la propagande alors même dans le mode
opératoire on va voir qu'on va assister
à une sorte de reconfiguration re
définition du jihadisme jihadistes dans
les années 90 le mode opératoire
principe principal utilisé par les
djihadistes était latente à la bande
suffit de se rappeler ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 90 par rapport aux actes
commis par le gie en france dans les
années 2000 le mode opératoire utilisé
par les djihadistes et l attentat
suicide
et au jour d'aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
qu'on assiste francs s'aperçoit que l'on
se développe un nouveau mode opératoire
qui consiste tout simplement à utiliser
des armes de poing touchant souvent des
militaires et on assiste effectivement
une sorte d'individualisation du
parcours ou du processus de
radicalisation qui s'affranchit du
groupe du leader charismatique
ok on avait habituellement affaire
pour toucher des militaires souvent des
militaires et donc la fermera et sans
doute on va dire la sphère qui est le
plus marqué les esprits mais il faut se
remémorer ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne par exemple en 2011 où une
personne d'origine kosovare a tué deux
soldats américains qui devaient se
rendre en afghanistan ou encore en 2010
l'exemple de la fusillade de fort hood
où une personne de confession musulmane
à soldats de confession musulmane a tué
13 soldats américains alors pour
conclure je voudrais effectivement vous
expliquer très de manière très rapide
que d'une manière générale la rhétorique
djihadistes s'articule autour de deux
points d'abord une critique de la
politique étrangère française en disant
effectivement que la france et à nice un
ennemi de l'islam des musulmans pour
preuve la france est engagée dans le
conflit en irak est engagée en
afghanistan et par conséquent la france
s'oppose à l'islam et mène une politique
belliqueuse à l'égard des musulmans
et c'est un point fondamental qui
explique en grande partie on va dire
l'impact que les leaders charismatiques
internet peut avoir auprès de personnes
qui décident de se radicaliser à partir
de cette de cet argument le deuxième
argument qui me semble être important et
qui expliquent le processus ou les
motivations des personnes qui décident
ce radicalisation se radicaliser
c'est la manière dont ces individus se
perçoivent en tant que musulmans vivant
en france considère que l'islam et par
les différentes polémiques qu'elle
suscite autour de la vie rurale elle
autour du voile intégral du voile taux
courts etc
suscitant va dire débat et
discrimination et l'individu qui se
radicalise d'une manière générale
considère que l'islam n'est pas le
bienvenu en france et kelly musulmans en
france bien qu'il soit de citoyenneté
française ont du mal à s'intégrer et
donc c'est à partir des ces deux
éléments à la fois la politique
étrangère française et en matière de
politique intérieure que les djihadistes
vont jouer et ce sont deux variables qui
pèse énormément dans les processus de
radicalisation
merci alors la deuxième elle est
incorporée effectivement dans la
première variable et c'est quelque chose
de relativement important parce que on
va effectivement les isr qui joue sur
internet on va souvent mobilisés cette
idée de conspiration en fait une
conspiration ou les juifs et les
occidentaux se seraient alliés pour
maintenir les musulmans sous domination
merci monsieur
c'était dans les temps et sur votre
sujet intéressant monsieur mathieu
guidère maintenant à vous et vous allez
vous présenter si monsieur le sénateur
mathieu guidère professeur des
universités agrégé d'arabe
j'ai été
professeur résidant à l'école spéciale
militaire de saint-cyr ensuite de 2003 à
2007 ensuite professeur de veille
stratégique à l'université de genève et
depuis 2011 je suis professeur
d'islamologie pensée arabe à
l'université de toulouse
le propos que je vais tenir n'a aucune
dimension partisane j'insiste là dessus
j'ai accepté cette invitation uniquement
à l'invitation de l'institution et non
pas d'une quelconque affaire politique
mon propos donc sera cadré sur ce qui a
été l'objet de de cette table ronde à
savoir d'évaluation de loi et je vais
essayer d'être assez bref pour permettre
les questions là dessus
j'insisterai sur deux points en disant
que la législation actuelle me paraît de
moins en moins pertinente au regard de
l'évolution du phénomène terroriste en
particulier parce que tous les acteurs
ont intégré les paramètres sécuritaires
et les techniques de surveillance
il y a deux phénomènes qui font que
cette législation est de moins en moins
pertinente
le premier phénomène c'est le contexte
international chamboulait il faut savoir
que enfin tout le monde le sait mais
c'est utile de le rappeler que depuis
il y a eu un changement radical de
situation au sud de la méditerranée et
il ya eu une évolution de la perception
au sein des communautés musulmanes au
nord de la méditerranée et notamment en
france la chute des dictatures et la
montée en puissance des forces
islamistes avec la victoire en
particulier des partis islamistes aux
élections en egypte en tunisie au maroc
et la tendance semble se confirmer pour
d'autres pays fait que cela a entraîné
une normalisation de l'islamisme
politique une normalisation de
l'islamisme politique sur la rive sud de
la méditerranée avec très important
c'est cela le phénomène qui nous vaut
une banalisation des thématiques
islamistes dans le champ public une
banalisation des thématiques islamistes
dans le champ public signifie une
focalisation sur l'identité musulmane
une insistance sur l'application de la
charia
à sur le port du voile sur la mixité
l'interdiction de la mixité des débats
sur la polygamie sur les sanctions
pénales donc l'amputation la lapidation
et c'est tout cela était auparavant très
très peu discuté et devient aujourd'hui
très banale sur la rive-sud et s'étend
sur la rive nord
la visibilité accrue des tendances
radicales de l'islamisme politique
notamment de la tendance est la fille
salafiste jihadiste dont il vient d'être
question jouit désormais cette tendance
radicale jouit désormais d'une liberté
d'expression et d'action inédite ce
contexte méditerranéen a bien évidemment
des répercussions sur le plan national
et sur le contexte national
les deux rives de la méditerranée
communique quotidiennement et
massivement entraînant une extension de
ce phénomène sur l'art de la rive sud
vers la rive nord et notamment en france
sur de nombreux territoires de la
république
cela se traduit par une importation de
problématiques nouvelles et par une
extension de comportement jusque-là
marginaux la communautarisation de la
vie locale et les allemands des
individus dans certains endroits
en l'absence de tout contrôle et de
suivi efficient je rappelle que ce suivi
ce contrôle étaient auparavant effectués
par les services la police politique des
différents pays en question et que nous
étions des charges et de ce contrôle de
ce suivi par ses victoires sur elle-même
et donc ce nouveau contexte constitue un
terreau favorable au développement de
nouveaux modes de sociabilité contraire
aux principes et aux valeurs de la
république parfois aussi c'est nouveau
contexte est favorable au basculement
dans l'action la plus violente
alors je répertorie ray indiquerait de
formes nouvelles de discours d'attitude
de comportement qui me paraissent
contraires aux valeurs et aux principes
de la république
le premier ce que j'appellerais le
prosélytisme en direct ce prosélytisme
indirects consiste à adopter une
attitude complaisante à l'égard des
expressions publiques qu'elles soient
antirépublicaines et antidémocratiques
antisémite
anti féminine racistes homophobes
sous couvert de justification religieuse
et de chercher à susciter l'adhésion du
public en faveur de ces expressions
haineuse en invoquant une légitimité
théologique
peu importe laquelle de ce point de vue
il y ce prosélytisme indirects également
accompagné d'un discours d'intimidation
ce discours d'intimidation peut être
mais nations hostiles et porte atteinte
à l'intégrité morale des personnes
puisque le système l'intégrité morale de
personnes signifie que le système de
valeurs bien mal de la personne est
remis en question
ou bien à l'intégrité physique puisque
la proximité physique parfois est trop
grande et la simple présence de la
personne fait peur ou encore à
l'intégrité psychologique de la personne
de nous par un processus des
dévalorisations d'humiliation ou
d'injures il me semble de ce point de
vue que le principe de précaution
devrait s'appliquer dans ce type de cas
l'absence de certitudes concernant
l'activité délictueuse ne doit pas
retarder l'adoption de mesures
effectives et proportionnées visant à
prévenir un risque terroriste dont ni
l'ampleur ni la probabilité d'occurrence
ne peuvent être envisagés avec certitude
en l'absence de certitude sur les
phénomènes ont cours et sur l'existence
du danger le risque était politique
certes mais cela ne signifie pas qu'il
est très peu probable voire négligeable
il s'agit d'une possibilité identifié
deux risques dont on ne connaît pas
précisément encore la probabilité mais
dans les citoyens doivent être protégés
ce principe de précaution son extension
aux deux mains terroristes permettrait
d'ailleurs par la même occasion de
responsabiliser tous les acteurs
quant à la portée de leur parole et de
leurs actes je le deuxième phénomène que
j'identifie et qui auquel il faudrait
que la législation finissent par
répondre un jour c'est celui de
l'intention l'intention agressive ou de
l'intention terroristes l'évolution du
terrorisme au cours des dernières années
j'ai écrit une vingtaine de livres
dans 5 e les 5 derniers 100 sur le
terrorisme et le dernier jeu les publié
il ya deux ans et s'intitule des
nouveaux terroristes
il parle exactement du phénomène que
nous venons de vivre en france récemment
et donc l'évolution du terrorisme au
cours des dernières années rend
l'anticipation est essentielle pour la
pratique protection des citoyens
or celle ci ne peut se faire sans une
prise en compte des intentions
agressives de certains individus qui
sont insiste conscients et responsables
de ce qu'ils envisagent de faire ou de
faire faire l'état actuel de la
législation française en matière de
sécurité intérieure et de lutte contre
le terrorisme ne prend pas suffisamment
en compte cette dimension essentielle de
la radicalité violente et il convient
d'en clarifier les tenants et les
aboutissants je distingue d'ailleurs à
ce niveau
l'intention est l'intentionnalité
l'intention c'est l'acte de volonté par
lequel il existe un but violent ou
agressif et le motif qui fait agir
tandis que l'intentionnalité c'est le
fait que l'individu est conscient de ce
qu'il fait ou de ce qu'il dit contraire
aux principes de la république
ces deux notions ne doivent pas être
confondus avec les mobiles
j'insiste c'est à dire les motifs
particuliers pour lesquelles l'individu
commis son geste
peu importe les justifications ce qui
importe ici c'est l'intentionnalité
agressive d'ailleurs mais je ne
m'attarderai pas là dessus
cette intention est agressive et codifié
dans le discours
en tout cas de terrorisme d'inspiration
islamiste puisque l'acte nouveau que par
l'intention et on pourrait la
littérature est très importante sur la
question de l'intentionnalité je tends
le djihadisme avec une justification à
la fois coranique une justification
théologique une justification chez dans
les actes du prophète
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que lorsque
l'individu veut passer à l'acte il le
doit le signaler
il doit en déclaré l'intention il doit
le faire intentionnellement c'est dans
ce maquis considère comme absurde
il n'a aucune valeur du point de vue
théologique c'est ce qui explique
d'ailleurs que les personnes en tendance
à filmer ou à laisser des testaments
après et a anticipé à dire ce qu'ils
vont faire parfois de façon très claire
il ya ne pas
caché à ne pas mentir sur leurs actes et
cela s'explique par une théologie de
l'intention qui est interne est
consubstantielle au terrorisme
d'inspiration islamiste
c'est droits et libertés ce qui m'amène
à dire que les droits et libertés
d'autrui doivent être protégés il faut
absolument éviter l'interdiction d'un
avis de droit en ce sens pour moi
avec le temps sur lequel j'ai travaillé
sur cette thématique et nous sommes que
la protection des individus doit
prévaloir
par rapport à la liberté de culte lutter
contre le terrorisme passe par une
adaptation de la législation française
pour pouvoir lutter efficacement contre
les intentions agressives souvent
revendiqués d'ailleurs comme
terrorisante par leurs auteurs il existe
une toute une théologie tout même
discours sur l'intention terrorisante
dans l'idéologie jihadiste celle ci se
manifeste ses intentions terrorisant
tous ses intentions agressives se
manifeste par des paroles par des actes
et par des attitudes spécifiques qui
sont aisément identifiables par les
spécialistes
reste à savoir le degré d'intention au
moment de l'infraction est ce qu'il est
aggravée cette intention à ce qu'elle
ait aggravé est ce qu'elle est éventuel
est ce qu'elle est déterminée
indéterminée cela signifie qu'ils
convient de préciser non pas la nature
de l'intention mais les critères
d'incrimination quant au contenu de
l'élément moral et déterminer les
contours exacts de l' intention
agressive la volonté de protéger la
personne humaine non seulement contre
les atteintes intentionnelle dont elle
peut être est victime mais encore contre
la négligence qui peut lui porter
préjudice devrait également pouvoir réel
qualifié sous certaines conditions comme
une mise en danger d'autrui
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup vous avez été très
concrètement dans le sujet qui qui qui
peut venir avec une nouvelle des
propositions sur une nouvelle
législation dans tous les cas vous
répondrais très clairement la question
sur est ce que la législation actuelle
et adaptées efficaces vous dit
clairement non et c'est une contribution
donc importante dans ce débat et bien
maintenant monsieur françois heisbourg
comme les autres vous allez vous
présenter
merci de ce président est donc je suis
conseiller spécial à la fondation pour
la recherche stratégique et j'ai fait
partie de la demi-douzaine de personnes
qui avaient préparé en 2005 livre blanc
sur la france face au terrorisme que
délivrant du gouvernement de l'époque
qui était là là la première tentative
raisonnablement abouti d'élaboration
d'une doctrine de lutte contre le
terrorisme et notamment celui dont on
parle aujourd'hui j'ai également cette
partie de la commission du livre blanc
sur la défense et la sécurité nationale
en 2008 et notamment des je faisais
partie du groupe restreint et qui a
réfléchi avec les chefs des services de
renseignement sur la réforme de la
communauté française du renseignement a
attrapé à cause de ça que je suis ici
aujourd'hui et j'ai également commis
une quelques livres mais deux que je me
permettrai d'évoquer en particulier d'un
que j'ai écrit en 2009 qui s'appelait
après al qaïda la nouvelle génération du
terrorisme c'est de penser à ce que
disait mathieu guidère il ya quelques
instants
et il y a trois ans il n'y avait aucun
problème aucun mystère pour arriver à la
conclusion est que le type de menaces
auxquelles on devait d'avoir à faire
dans les années suivantes allaient être
le type de menaces laquelle on m'a eu à
faire dans les années suivantes et
notamment sur mesure vue à toulouse le
profil ou solitaires pouvait être
dessinée sans grande difficulté dès
cette époque et deuxième livre 2012 donc
quelques semaines espionnage et
renseignements le vrai dossier chez
odile jacob où j'évoque notamment est là
la réforme des services qui a été mise
en place à partir de 2008 et plusieurs
questions et d'abord l'évolution de la
de la menace donc déjà parlé samir
amghar à ma joie et de c'est un
excellent tableau je vais me hasarder un
parallèle et ce à quoi nous assistons et
est à bien des égards comparable à ce
que nous avons vécu au niveau des des
modes de radicalisation au niveau des
modes d'expression de la violence y
compris à travers le témoignage dont il
a été question il ya quelques instants
ça ressemble beaucoup à ce qu'on a connu
pour des années 70 dans un tout autre
cadre idéologique était celui du
marxisme fondamentalistes si je puis
dire
j'invente l'expression au passage et de
la route armée fraktion des cellules
communistes combattantes en belgique
d'action directe en france des brigades
rouges en italie ce qui est une autre
façon de dire est qu'il y aurait autant
d'erreurs à aborder la lutte contre le
terrorisme
aujourd'hui à travers le prisme de la
réflexion sur le problème d'intégration
et
des des français d'origines professant
la religion musulmane qui en aurait eu
pendant des années soixante dix a
considéré qu'il y avait un problème
marxiste n'est pas un problème marxiste
il y avait un problème de terrorisme qui
affichait une certaine idéologie et mais
ce n'est pas en s'attaquant une
idéologie quant à les résoudre le
problème du terrorisme et je pense que
ce rappel la peut servir la question de
l'adéquation de la législation et
dansons sa lettre et dans son
application est ici je serai moins
formelle que mathieu guidère et notre
arsenal juridique est très
impressionnant bien des pays
pour reprendre une expression un
véhicule et nous l'envient la
l'incrimination de de complicité de
participation à une entreprise
terroriste ce formidable ça permet de
faire à peu près ce que l'on veut et le
régime des interceptions de sécurité a
parlé aux anglais et aux américains de
notre régime en matière d'interception
de sécurité à une nous ça il aimerait
bien voir ça et regarder le
fonctionnement
il va l'existence et le fonctionnement
du pôle judiciaire matière de terrorisme
regardez le régime des gardes à vue très
honnêtement cet arsenal là il est il a
proliféré il s'est développé au fil des
ans et je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait
autre chose à y faire que d'y apporter
quelques adaptations je vais y venir
dans un instant et surtout veillez bien
sur ce bonne application des demandes
d'adaptation à l'arial problème
d'internet on a tout à fait raison de
s'y appesantir et parce que le loup
solitaire parler de lui dans bien des
cas il va s'être radicalisés auto
radicalisés
le terme n'est pas totalement exact
lorsque vous êtes sur internet il vous
arrive d'interagir votre radicalisation
n'est pas n'est pas purement solitaire t
ce n'est pas comme si vous lisez un
livre sur le sur le djihadisme ce qui
est une autre façon de dire que en
matière d'internet et ce qui doit à mon
sens faire l'objet dé des mesures les
plus attentives et tout ce qui concerne
justement d'interactivité tout ce qui
est fort sommes tous qui êtes chatte
tout ce qui est blog et c'est ce biais
là qui me paraît devoir être regardé de
très près on a bien sûr un parallèle
dont on peut s'inspirer et je pense
qu'ils mériteraient d'être d'être poussé
notamment par le joli par les
techniciens du domaine c'est la lutte
contre la cyberpédophilie c'est je crois
qu'on a là un parallèle dont on peut
assez bien et s'inspirer ça chante aussi
et c'est la nature du du du média dont
on parle dont on parle ici et que on ne
sera réellement efficace et que si on
parvient à obtenir la participation la
coopération active de l'ensemble de nos
part de nos partenaires
ça existe dans le domaine de la lutte
contre la cyberpédophilie je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait de raison a priori pour
qu'il ne puisse pas en aller de même
dans la lutte contre la cyber
radicalisation et la préparation d'actes
de terrorisme par la voix de la
cybernétique et l'application et de la
loi et de la politique antiterroriste et
on a connu au début des années 1980
puisque c'est à cette époque là qu'est
né lé dispositif actuel une fois au plan
des lois et aux plans d organisation des
institutions en a connu à partir du
début des années 1980 un développement
progressif
pas toujours simple et mais en fait
assez réussi et de la coordination de la
lutte antiterroriste dans l'ensemble de
ses dimensions dans ses dimensions
d'investigation et dans ses dimensions
de répression policière et judiciaire
et c'est cela qui nous a permis de fait
à partir de 1996 de ne pas connaître
d'actes de terrorisme réussie sur notre
territoire
jusqu'à cette année et qu'est ce qui
peut expliquer que les choses se soient
mal passé en 2012 je ne forcerai pas de
répondre de façon systématique à cette
question je crois que quand d'entre nous
aujourd'hui encore les données en main
et mais à travers les différentes
déclarations qui ont été faites par les
responsables notamment ce que vous
vouliez entendre je pense nous battrons
delà des séries en particulier un je
constate que des questions ont été
posées sur le niveau de coopération
entre services en intra national comme
international en intra nationale il a
été dit que la dgse ne vais pas alerté
la des séries il a en international il a
été dit que les américains n'avaient pas
alerté les services français je ne sais
pas si c'est le cas ou pas mais le
simple fait que ce type de déclaration
puisse être formulée par un responsable
important la lutte contre le terrorisme
en france et jette une ombre sur le
tableau relativement serein et que moi
je me faisais au moment de nos travaux
2005 en 2008
en ce qui concerne la coopération
internationale et sur la coopération au
sein de la communauté française du
renseignement
j'ouvre une parenthèse cette expression
communauté française du renseignement a
été une des innovations sémantique
de 2008 2009 elle fait partie elle
figure aujourd'hui dans les textes
officiels
mais pour qu'il y ait communauté il faut
quand même qu'il y a une culture du
partage
je ne suis pas sûr que la culture du
partage soit aussi poussée qu'elle ne
doive d'être donc ça c'est sont les
interrogations que j'ai que je n'avais
pas avant que très honnêtement que je
n'aurais pas formulé avant toulouse
temps le bilan était impressionnant et
deuxième
deuxième élément est lorsque nous avons
fait les préconisations du livre blanc
en 2008 parmi ses préconisations il y
avait un développement important des
moyens alloués à ce qu'on appelait la
fonction stratégique connaissance et
anticipation façon polie de dire entre
autres le renseignement et à la dgse en
a profité à plein le budget de la
direction générale de la sécurité
extérieure a augmenté de façon très
considérable ses effectifs ont été très
largement étoffé avec d'excellents
éléments je dois d'ajouter et on a
l'impression d'une machine qui tourne et
d'une machine qui au plan budgétaire et
a bénéficié dans la pratique des
recommandations qui avait été fait en ce
qui concerne le renseignement intérieur
nous sommes dans une situation un peu
différente est d'une part la des séries
n'est pas une direction générale elle
est budgétairement une variable
dépendante dans la direction générale de
la police nationale
le budget de la des séries évolue en
fonction de ce qu'est la dgpn et capable
de lui donner en la dgpn d'après ce que
j'ai pu comprendre vivaient dans un état
de relative diète dans le cadre de la
révision générale des politiques
publiques
donc les premiers problèmes j'allais
dire de pure moyens qui se posent
peut-être je ne sais pas si c'est un
facteur explicatif de quoi que ce soit
mais je constate c'est le coup de boost
qui a pu être fait pour le renseignement
extérieur pour des raisons largement
terre
hb titus ionel organisationnel n'a pas
pu être fait dans les mêmes proportions
pour le renseignement intérieur nous
savons par ailleurs que le renseignement
intérieur est encore en train et c'est
tout à fait normal et de procéder à la
fusion décidée il ya plus de quatre ans
maintenant de la dst et des
renseignements généraux or préfecture de
police c'est une fusion qui comme toutes
les grandes fusions quelques natures
quechua est logiquement difficiles
compliquées entre deux organisations de
cultures très différentes et infusions
par ailleurs que je considère comme
nécessaire je suis pas du tout en train
de procéder à cette à une critique de
cette de cette décision de m
mais pour arriver à la ligne de résultat
et je que je considère qu' on peut
toiletter les dispositifs législatifs
notamment pour la dimension cybernétique
nous n'avons pas à le reprendre et en ce
qui concerne l'application des
dispositions existantes et il y à un
chantier inabouti à l'heure actuelle en
ce qui concerne le renseignement
intérieur tant en termes de moyens que
probablement aussi en ce qui concerne sa
logique d'organisation
je pense que le renseignement intérieur
devrait bénéficier de son autonomie
budgétaire à la manière de la dgse
d'autant plus je conclus là dessus que
dès lors que le ministère de l'intérieur
a en main propre la gendarmerie
nationale il y aurait une logique à ce
que le renseignement intérieur soit
positionné de façon homothétique par
rapport à la police nationale d'un côté
par rapport à la gendarmerie nationale
de l'autre alors qu'aujourd'hui le
renseignement intérieur marche sur un
pied et non pas sur deux jambes
bien merci beaucoup encore les années la
façon de traiter le sujet des questions
qu'on veut poser aussi très très
précieux et j'ai cru discerner une
position sensiblement différent de celle
qui était exprimé avant / / / la
question de la législation vous avez
souligné en particulier le fait qu'il ya
une législation pas des sections
d'exception dans tous les cas assez
exceptionnel par rapport à d'autres
grandes démocraties qui se vouent lutte
contre le terrorisme sur les
possibilités notamment de deux de
prévenir
l'intention est d'ailleurs je vous
poserai ensuite monsieur leader quelles
questions sur la précision de ce que
voulait dire quels domaines faudrait
aller encore plus loin pour pour arrêter
au moment de l' intention
de l'acte puisque la réputation de la
législation française et qu'elle est
déjà assez avancé dans ce domaine enfin
bon on va sera dans le débat et bien
maintenant monsieur daniel martin et
ensuite on passera aux questions des
sénateurs et sénatrices présent merci
monsieur le président je vais me
retourner auprès de mon obtenir de
droite en le remerciant de ce qu'il a pu
dire parce que je suis commissaire
divisionnaire honoraire qui a fait 22
ans de carrière à la dst où j'ai monté
le département des systèmes
d'information quand j'entends ça ça veut
revigore un petit peu parce que je dis
bon on n'est pas les seuls à penser ce
qu'on pense
mais comme dirait pierre dac on a bien
raison quand on sait ce qu'on voit et
qu'on va ce conseil dont on avait raison
de penser ce qu'on pense mais bon
toujours est il pour pour revenir à plus
de sérieux que là je vais aborder mois
le plus tôt le sujet vous dire un peu
qu'ils qui je suis pas ce que j'ai fait
une carrière à la dst pendant 22 ans
puis après je me suis orienté vers
l'international où j'étais chef de
service allo c d e où je me suis prêté
ses problèmes de sécurité puis après à
la cour des comptes comme
rapporteur extérieur et où j'ai pu donc
voir un certain nombre de choses qui
m'ont j'allais dire édifier et j'ai créé
ensuite institut international des
hautes études de cybercriminalité parce
que je pense depuis les années 70 que la
cybercriminalité quelque chose qui est
j'allais dire qui qui qui qui va
exploser dans les années à venir encore
plus qu'aujourd'hui et donc j'essaie de
sensibiliser sur ce domaine et je prends
mon bâton de pèlerin et je suis donc au
comité français défense civile aussi où
je participe à la rédaction d'un certain
nombre de choses et rassurez vous la
semaine dernière on m'a annoncé comme
décédé parce que j'ai en aumône homme
qui est anonyme qui est qui et qui est
décédé et j'ai pu lire ma nécrologie sur
internet et ça fait quelque chose
j'ai bien content d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui le pen normalement on avait
déjà ce professionnel votre parcours
ben oui mais avec ma photo donc c'est
fait donc ça fait un choc tout de même
enfin c'était oui c'était pas mal je
suis dit tiens ben je suis quand même un
des rares à avoir pu voir ma nécrologie
c'est quand même incroyable enfin je
voudrais très rapidement faire un rappel
de la situation en m'orientant plus si
vous voulez vers le côté globale puisque
le terrorisme et qu'une partie de 2,2
des activités qui peuvent même me
rattacher à la cybercriminalité
en fait je voudrais vous donner quelques
chiffres 1 rapidement il ya y avait
remis en 2007 1 milliard de de
d'ordinateurs personnels dans le monde
il y en aura deux milliards cette année
imaginez ce que ça donne
aujourd'hui nous sommes toujours en
train d'appliquer la loi dans l'espace
et dans le temps
1 % du monde la france mais à côté de ça
on a un un maillage globale qui existe
maintenant depuis un certain temps et
qui est utilisé par là par tous ces gens
là parce et quand je dis 2 milliard de
pc ça veut dire qu'il ya plusieurs
personnes qui sont sur ses pc bien sûr
ça veut dire également qu'il ya 200
milliards de spams par jour on sert des
courriers non sollicités
si je considère qu'il ya seulement 0,3
pour cent de criminels sur le sur le net
diront 3% s'est pas beaucoup ça
représente ou même 3 millions de
criminels potentiels
et puis cette criminalité allez
maintenant j'allais dire avec une
dimension variable
avant on avait les les cambrioleurs on
avait les voleurs de banque on avait les
escrocs les etc etc
aujourd'hui ils sont multi cartes c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils utilisent
internet pour effectuer des escroqueries
on en connaît et on pourrait revenir
dessus
et puis avec cet argent là mais vont
acheter des armes épée que césar de
commettre des attentats et c'est donc la
frontière on peut plus rangé les gens
dans les cases habituel aujourd'hui le
monde et c'est une nébuleuse et c'est
une nébuleuse mondiale alors évidemment
là dedans internet joue un rôle et pour
revenir plus précisément sur notre sujet
il ya plus en plus de moyens disponibles
ils sont de moins en moins cher ils sont
disponibles donc à tout le monde ce qui
était possible pour les services
étatiques les maintenant pour n'importe
qui vous voulez écouter le téléphone
portable de quelqu'un très facile pour
moins de 100 euros vous acheter un
logiciel que vous téléchargez assez
facilement et vous pouvez suivre tout ce
qui se passe donc quand je vois que
souvent on met en cause les services
étatiques pour l'heure leur intrusion
dans la vie privée
je lis mais attendez voir le danger le
big brother c'est pas forcément les
services étatiques
c'est un peu tout le monde aujourd'hui
et ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup parce que
on ne sait pas trop comment faire face à
tout ça
oui mais tout le monde personne quand on
est victime c'est ça je me mets à la
place des victimes
aujourd'hui on est dans un mode où on
sait on sait qui vous êtes
on sait ce que vous êtes en train de
faire on sait où vous vous situez
géolocalisation on sait quels sont vos
goûts et vos préférences
la plupart du temps ce que vous pensez
sur sur beaucoup de sujets et en plus
c'est vous qui fusaient c'est à dire que
là on reprocherait un service national
représentatif de 2 de demander un
certain nombre d'informations justifier
alors là on commence à se poser la
question qu'est ce que c'est que ces
intrusions et cetera dans la vie réelle
on commence à diffuser les choses et si
vous avez lu la presse ces jours ci lui
fc que choisir a lancé un un bon poisson
d'avril en demandant un certain nombre
d'informations à des clients potentiels
et les gens à 98% ont donné les
informations
tout ça pour gagner un billet de loterie
ou des choses comme ça donc attention le
monde est différent et ce monde
différent moi je dis briques brazzers
n'est pas celui qu'on croyait on se
méfie de l'état mais le risque vient
surtout j'ai à dire des réseaux sociaux
où chacun y met volontairement c'est un
fou très personnelle je pars en vacances
pour deux semaines à tel endroit donc
parfait pour les cambrioleurs on sait
que votre appartement est disponible
enfin toujours est il que pour revenir à
notre sujet mais il n'est pas loin de
tout ça parceque ils baignent dans cette
atmosphère si vous voulez je dirais que
aujourd'hui et quand j'étais dans les
services de renseignement on avait une
grande formule qui résume un peu tout le
renseignement est tombé d'informations
exploitables et évaluer les différences
entre l'information et le renseignement
eh bien c'est ce que j'appelle la règle
des huit tu es tout savoir sur tout tout
le temps en temps réel ça fait 8 t avais
dis donc quel programme des américains
se sont cassé les dents avec échelon à
on en vient est chez nous mais vous
savez à vouloir tout augure jt il ya des
milliers de langage sur terre et ma foi
il ya quand même une limite c'est que
quand vous écoutez quelque chose que
vous ne comprenez pas falloir appel il
faut faire appel à un interprète
un traducteur est bien là ça prend du
temps et ils n'ont pas vu les choses
venir et donc on peut pas tout faire
tout le temps surtout
j'allais dire heureusement pour nous
pour nos propres libertés quelque chose
également qui est important sur internet
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'anonymat vous
avez tous vu à le groupe anonymous etc
qui revendique un certain d'actions etc
c'est un peu gênant parce que on confond
souvent l'anonymat et la confidentialité
sont deux choses différentes
imaginez la circulation à paris s'il n'y
avait pas de plaque minéralogique sur
les voitures
je peux vous dire que les feux rouges ne
sera sans doute pas bien respecté
c'était c'est évident mais toujours est
il qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'utilisateurs d'internet savent
utiliser les procédures pour qu'on ne
puisse pas remonter jusqu'à eux
et ça c'est extrêmement grave et ça va
entraîner sans doute des des
conséquences au niveau de la
réglementation qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
etc on y viendra tout à l'heure les
sites internet bien sûr vous avez parlé
de prosélytisme oui ça va jusqu'à la
diffusion d'image de décapitation des
shows enfin des choses
insoutenable si vous voulez hein mais il
ya aussi les recettes pour fabriquer les
bombes pour comment se forme et comment
d'échangés vous savez il utilise aussi
ces fameuses boîtes aux lettres dans les
temps d'espionnage une boîte aux lettres
mort c'est votre
alors on ne peut pas maintenant
surveiller l'internet contrôlée
quelqu'un qui va aller consulter une
boîte aux lettres située à hong kong au
panama au costa rica et bien donc il
consulte il rien de transit sur le net
ils vont simplement voir et ça
ça pose quand même un problème les
discours de radicalisation sur internet
les forums des tchats les blogs
pm dire appartement où ça existe les
services peuvent très bien se brancher
dessus mais on reviendra sur les sur les
moyens après les réseaux sociaux n'en
parlons pas il y en a des milliers
vous pouvez faire des vous pouvez bon
très peu de temps et est pratiquement
gratuitement créé votre propre réseau
social sur le net on vous y encourage
etc et je vais dans la graduation de
dangerosité
il existe aussi à côté d'internet dit de
surface un internet invisible qu'est ce
que c'est selon l'université de berkeley
en californie cet internet invisible
c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas accessible
par les moteurs de recherche classique
que nous connaissons tous
ils seraient plus de 500 fois plus grand
que l'internet de surface bon ça ça
m'inquiète aussi parce que ça m'inquiète
mais on retombe toujours sur le facteur
humain
c'est ce qui moi m'a passionné toute la
carrière c'est l'internet invisible
c'est non non non non pas du tout
l'internet invisible c'est l'internet
que vous moi
quiconque ne connaît pas parce que quand
vous posez une question sur un des
moteurs de recherche disponibles il ne
vous répond pas parce qu'ils essaient
ces différentes sites ne sont pas
connectés ne sont pas référencé dans les
moteurs de recherche
sur le net de tous leurs produits et
vous pouvez y accéder vous pouvez parier
sur mes bases de données qui sont
derrière l'équipe et il est bien sûr
chez elle alors mais attendez ça va au
delà de l'intranet vous avez des sites
totalement spécifique qui sont pas d
intranet les intranet en étant un petit
peu malin on arrive quand même à
franchir la barrière et mais vous avez
ce qu'on appelle tort ter et non pas
tous verte et 10 onion router qui est un
logiciel qui vous permet justement
d'être totalement anonyme dans ce monde
souterrain qui n'est pas accessible
j'allais dire ou commun des mortels on
se bat et qui sont accessibles
uniquement parce qu'ils sont initiées
par ça alors à bas et c'est toujours
pareil
c'est le facteur humain qui va
déclencher soeur parce que et on parlait
des loups solitaires tout à l'heure
c'est un peu la même chose un loup
solitaire néo n'est pas vraiment
solitaire au départ il sait il a
commencé à ceux à se former et puis
après il a quand même besoin de diffuser
un peu d'informations on l'a vu dans le
cas de l'as de toulouse
effectivement on est solitaire ce sens
est totalement et ce qui se perd c'est
ce dialogue en routeur c'est
effectivement que à un moment ou un
autre ces gens là apparaît 0 il laisse
une trace quelque part mais cette trace
encore faut-il avoir les moyens de la
soulever et de lever lors au même titre
que les hackers étaient des pirates
pénétrer infiltrés voir manipuler on
peut penser aussi que sur l'ensemble de
ces différentes sites et réseaux sociaux
ma foi
il ya des gens dont c'est le métier de
regarder un peu comme les motards de la
route 1 on a les autoroutes de
l'information il semble légitime que sur
ses autoroutes de l'information est un
peu d'ironie fleurs et qu'on s'aperçoive
ceux qui grillent les feux rouges ce qui
envoie on l'a vu pour la
pédopornographie ça semble tout à fait
logique d'arrêter des gens qui
pratiquent ce genre de chose quoique je
me souviens d'une affaire à l'époque où
j'étais encore en fonctions où
effectivement une des premières
personnes qui a été arrêté dans le cadre
d'une opération de larges de pédophilie
c'était le journaliste qui avait monté
et et dénoncer cette affaire parce que
lui même avait essayé bien sûr de
regarder bon mais il a été arrêté comme
les autres évidemment c'est rapidement
la garde à vue était de lever enfin tout
de même tout de même alors attention on
nous dit aussi je veux tout contrôler et
surtout danger on parle notamment aux
états unis de ce qu'on appelle le deep
packet inspection inspecter tous les
paquets de données qui transitent par
tous les opérateurs
j'allais dire et pico encore ils n'ont
pas compris avec échelon on veut
recommencer ça semble si vous voulez
d'abord très restrictif au plan des
libertés et ensuite peu opérationnel
parce que il faut pouvoir trouver ce
qu'on veut c'est ce que je voulais dire
à travers cette petite exposés c'est que
les risques en rallye états sont globaux
en réalité sont globaux on a les états
parce que n'oublions pas tout de même
que les états moi j'ai connu la période
où les états y avait des états
terroristes les états avec la
prolifération que l'on voit ils ont une
action aussi un on peut on peut se poser
au moins la question est-ce qu'il ya
encore des services étatiques capable de
manipuler ou d'envoyer des informations
et rené les organisations des
organisations terroristes qui ont accès
à tout ça les entreprises n'oublions pas
que aujourd'hui dans un monde global où
bien des entreprises je ne citerai pas
en des budgets qui dépasse les budgets
des états prenez coca cola unilever etc
dont ils ont des pouvoirs ces gens là
sont capables de faire des choses sont
capables de faire de l'espionnage ils
sont capables de de faire des
contrefaçons voir la chine et ses
terrains et n'oublions pas non plus les
individus donc ceci sonne toujours la
société en tranches l'état les
organisations et et puis d'un autre côté
à la fin des citoyens que nous sommes
alors on a vu l'iran on a vu la syrie on
a vu ce tucson est le fameux virus qui a
infecté les centrifugeuses iraniennes
donc là on peint on peut penser qu'à des
organisations voir des états qui ont
financé ou provoquer tout ceci les
criminels sont multi coeurs joué 10 et
notre sujet c'est aussi de mêlée on
parle des sources technique on a
beaucoup soulevé le problème des sources
techniques mais on a vu là où les
américains ont abouti en négligeant les
sources humaines nous en france c'est
plutôt les sources humaines est-ce que
c'est plus facile vous comprenez comme
on n'a pas de moyens s'étaient soulevées
par notre notre ami à côté le problème
c'est que ben il faut bien qu'on se
sorte de de quelque chose il faut avoir
des services de documentation et
d'analysé fiable
c'est à dire pas comme je vois encore
aujourd'hui des stagiaires en transit
parce que les gens ils rêvent que d'être
sur le macadam avec un avec un revolver
ou une armée plus pour arrêter des
terroristes mais se fait pas comme ça
il ya un travail de fond de profondeur
qui s'apparente plus d'ailleurs au
contre espionnage ou à la contre
ingérence
parce que le contre terrorisme c'est ça
aussi c'est beaucoup de travail en amont
et beaucoup de coopération
il faut investir donc dans l'information
et je terminerai en vous donnant
quelques propositions parce que j'aime
bien sûr travailler beaucoup là-dessus
donner des moyens supplémentaires
humains logiciels matériels mutualiser
des moyens quand j'ai vécu
dst dgse j'aurais bien aimé avoir les
moyens de mes amis vous le voir mortier
les etats unis ont compris depuis
longtemps fbi à une université
ça travaille ensemble il faut diffuser
des informations retour parce que quand
vous quand vous donner des informations
vous n'avez jamais de retour vous en
donner plus il faut dialoguer au niveau
international c'est recréer des stages
communs je vais participer à des stages
communs notamment avec les américains et
je pense que là c'est très important
en fait ce vers quoi on va si les
services étatiques n'ont pas les moyens
de leur de leurs actions c'est vers une
privatisation des moyens d'action j'ai
été très étonnée hier de voir que google
et ses moyens avec l'acteur clooney que
vous connaissez tous
elle a dénoncé les crimes contre
l'humanité en diffusant des images par
satellite et je trouve que ça ça veut
dire donc les services classiques ils
sont dépassés parce que la machine
la machine elle continue d'avancer et si
j'appelle de mes voeux aussi les
réformes qui ont été soulevés tout à
l'heure pour conclure sur la législation
je considère que c'est pas mal c'est
effectivement on nous envie tout ça on
en vit les services de renseignement
étrangers nous envient
le fait d'avoir une des séries qui
traite aussi du judiciaire parce qu'ils
ne doivent pas le faire et ils ne
regardent et les américains ici trouve
effectivement que notre arsenal n'est
pas mal maintenant ils demandent comme
d'habitude toujours à s'adapter et je
crois qu'effectivement grâce au travail
de la commission comme la vôtre
on arrivera à progresser dans le bon
sens merci
écouter à nouveau merci beaucoup pour
ces quatre exposés qui sont très
complémentaires et y compris qui
indépendamment de leur complémentarité
sur les sujets sous permettre le débat
parce qu'ils en filigrane développe des
points de vue qui peuvent être
différents sur ce qu'il ya à faire
maintenant
donc voilà je vais passer la parole en
sachant que vraiment nous avoir quitté
les lieux à 11h10 parce qu'il ya un gros
politique qui doit faire sous son règne
au groupe ici est donc faux faut qu'on
soit parti je prends un ensemble de
questions en bloc pas une à une et qu'on
essaie de formuler de façon très
synthétique pour que vous puissiez
répondre et on fera une petite
conclusion
merci jean pierre
merci à tous les cas pas parce que j'ai
aussi été très intéressés comme nous
tous parce que vous avez dit j'ai juste
une question
j'ai été frappé par la différence de
tonalité entre le propos de monsieur
iceborg et de monsieur khider et
monsieur as beau vous avez tenu un
propos je qualifierais finalement de
réformistes vous avez dit on est dans un
système où on a un arsenal juridique
impressionnant et vous avez dit qu'il
fallait s'inspirer de ce qui existe en
matière de cyber pédophilie vous avez
aussi pointé du doigt le fait qu'il y
avait un manque de coordination
par exemple dgse des séries par exemple
des séries gendarmerie par exemple entre
l'amérique et la france
monsieur guidère vous avez commencé en
disant la législation est de moins en
moins pertinente
tous les acteurs l'ont intégré ce qui
est un point de vue différent vous dit
finalement les acteurs eux savent
connaissent tous les tous les recoins de
la législation il en joue et il passe à
côté
donc notre législation ne marche pas et
vous avez dit il ya un point qui est
très important c'est l'intention ou
l'intentionnalité mais alors nous en
tant que législateur ça nous rend dans
la perplexité
car la question que je voulais vous
poser bon c'est très intéressant car ces
deux points de vue parce que ça permet
d'essayer d'avancer mais la question
c'est comment pénalisé l'intention c'est
ça le problème
on a tous dans la tête sans doute des
tas de choses qui passent rendez compte
si on entrer là dedans
en fait la loi elle fonctionne par
rapport à des actes
c'est très difficile de alors peut-être
palente ils vont alors justement je pose
la question comme non merci
même chose mais alors on essaye vraiment
d'être ramassés pour qu'ils aient du
temps aux réponses parce qu'on attend
des réponses
alors monsieur d'abord marie noëlle
lienemann ensuite monsieur gaëtan gorce
en suisse laurence rossignol
je clos la liste je clos la liste
allez-y
c'est une question tout à fait
fondamental ce qui a besoin de renforcer
une législation qui rentre dans l'idée
de l'attention de nuit afin extra et
comment on peut le connecter parce que
si on veut faire rentrer ce concept il
doit s'appliquer à tous les terrorismes
donc aux corses heures ou à le terrain
puisque je rappelle qu'en europe c'est
pal terrorisme islamique qui est
majoritaire en europe les terrorismes
dominants sont des terrorismes
régionalistes
donc il est ou nationaliste a donc par
nature fâche par l'adp l'europe en
général mais en france c'est pas tout à
fait vrai puisque évidemment la force de
le des années pas la même question
comment le concept que vous développez
dont on voit bien la cohérence par
rapport notamment humala motivations de
ce que vous ai dis sur l'islam y ce
pourrait être aussi valable pour toutes
les formes de terrorisme
deuxièmement ça ramène à ce que disait
monsieur heisbourg est-ce que ce
terrorisme et de nature finalement
radicalement différent l'histoire de la
commune ap sales mecs individuelles qui
fait son truc avec la marque al-qaïda
est-ce que c'est radicalement différent
des autres formes de refus des systèmes
sociaux et de espèce de mythologie de se
raccrocher à un truc internationale ou
historiques pour justifier je ne sais
quelle dérive donc en tout cas ça c'est
le deuxième point mais moi je suis
beaucoup plus dubitatif que vous sur le
lien entre le communautarisme et les
individus isolés qui agissent se trouve
que par expérience personnelle assez
dramatique enfin j'ai recruté un emploi
jeune qui s'est retrouvé six ans en
prison pour liens avec al qaïda et je
peux vous dire que rien en plus mon côté
l'écart à bien un allié donne une
méthode fait que moi je suis à ces
secteurs là dessus rien ne pouvait
d'autres jeunes n'avaient aucun lien
avec les quartiers il venait d'un grand
lycée parisien où il avait parfaitement
réussi ses études scientifiques
et il était quand je les recruter dans
un syndrome que j'appelle de
victimologie jeu pour que la route est
encore non plongeurs jeudi vous ai plein
diplôme pourquoi parce que je suis arabe
on veut pas m'embaucher mois bonne pâte
je me suis dit c'est vrai que ça arrive
puisque j'ai des cas très précis autour
de moi où je n'ai vu donc je dis moi je
vous donnais à moyenne démarrer dans la
vie
je me suis rendu compte que sa
frustration principal n'était pas le
communautarisme il n'était absolument
pas religieux au démarrage et s'est
radicalisé par des mécanismes
psychologiques qui sont par ailleurs
idéologique qui arrive à d'autres
j'aurais donc tendance à donner raison à
monsieur heisbourg pour ce cas précis et
je mets en garde contre la corrélation
communautarisme quartier par ailleurs
une dérive grave pour d'autres raisons
avec la question terroriste mais est-ce
qu'on a des statistiques si je puis dire
des profils socio culturel moi j'avais
été frappé aussi de voir les
palestiniens qui se font sauter la
beaucoup sur universitaire et lorsqu'une
dramatique je suis scientifique beaucoup
sont scientifiques
donc je voulais savoir si on avait une
étude des profils
merci gaëtan et ensuite laurence
rampillon trois questions et j'ai été
frappé par ce que vous avez dit monsieur
heisbourg sur le fait qu'il faut mettre
de côté la doctrine c'est jeudi à pour
le traité clés du ciel façon les faits
sont là l'acte terroriste et sa
répression
pour autant est-ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui regard du contexte parce que
dans lequel nous sommes arrivés à une
évaluation de la menace
il ya même si on met de côté
effectivement à sonder les ventes il ne
faut pas surestimer l'influencé aucun
d'entre vous ne nous a donné des
indications peut être plus précis joue
plus subjectif sur ce que peut être
aujourd'hui la menace son origine et son
importance la deuxième question elle est
sur les problèmes de coordination qui
ont été relevés par jean pierre sueur
est-ce que ça appel de votre part des
réformes de structure supplémentaire et
que celles qui ont déjà été engagées
notamment s'agissant l'organisation du
renseignement français
est ce que supposent également de
nouveaux supports juridiques avec nos
partenaires et y compris avec les etats
unis pour que ces terres en information
fonctionne mieux
ou est-ce que ça relève de la pratique
troisième question pour aller vite on a
évoqué l'importance de l'arsenal dont
nous disposons vous avez dit avec un
sourire mais néanmoins un élément de
vérité forcément que nous avions un
arsenal que pouvez-nous janvier ça pose
le web du contrôle qui peut s'exercer
alors sur l'utilisation et arsenal
est-ce que c'est au coeur même du débat
que nous avons eu c'est aujourd'hui ce
contrôle tels que certains peuvent
exercer notamment par le bond est ce qui
vous paraît aujourd'hui disposer de
moyens suffisants car qui dit moyens
importants et on peut souhaiter pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
je suppose d'un point de vue
démocratique des moyens de contrôles
adaptés attention là parce qu'il n'y
aura pas de réponses à vos questions et
tu as donné qu'il reste 10 minutes et
que ils pourront pas répondre à tous si
vous vous en poser trop allait lancer
pew
maintenant moi aussi je veux faire un
peu de victimisation de temps en temps 3
3 3 question rapidement la première
qu'est pour monsieur gars vous avez
conclu votre propos en disant que parmi
les facteurs de radicalité il y avait le
fait que l'islam de radicalisation
ballon fait que l'islam avec la
polémique qu'il suscite est considéré
comme n'étant pas bienvenus en france
mais en grande bretagne où le rapport
est assez différent il n'y a pas pour
autant de corrélation sur une moindre
point d'attractivité de la
radicalisation chez des musulmans
fondamentalistes britannique donc est ce
comme il fallait ce que vous pourriez
était un tout petit peu ça parce que
c'est un débat là-dessus donc et il est
présent ce serait bien de le pousser la
deuxième sur la part des facteurs même
je rejoins marina lienemann quand on a
dix points à des profils et ce coin
c'est un peu plus encore que peut-être
il faut dire que dans le passage à
l'acte si on n'a pas un énorme panel
intel de préciser le précédent était
quand même il ya quelques temps le panel
donc non pas énorme mais bon en revanche
dans des éléments qui sont qu'ils sont
repérés
moi j'ai été très frappée quand on a
autour du du profil de molène merom
j'étais le matin même à une conférence
de pierre joxe qui sur les tribunaux
pour enfants
juste pour enfants faisait remarquer
qu'un tiers des enfants qui sont
tribunal tant enfants n'ont pas de
perdre un tiers ont un père mon paternel
et un tiers seulement on perd ce qui est
quand même une sur-représentation par
rapport à ceux de la société des enfants
en déficit paternel et j'ai entendu de
la famille raconte et de ceux de ce
garçon et je trouve qu'ils avaient quand
même aussi des similarités et peut-être
qu'on s'intéresse beaucoup beaucoup au
delà dimension communautariste peut-être
qu'on pourra s'intéresse aussi à des
facteurs de déstructuration familiale et
psychologiques qui sont qu'une dent qui
ne sont pas spécifiques à aucune
communauté
et enfin je suis assez troublé par
l'application du principe de précaution
autant je trouve que la formule est
séduisante parce qu'elle est
intellectuellement agile mais je vois
pas quand même jusqu'à quel point on
peut poser comme principe que sous
prétexte que la cybercriminalité et tout
le cybermonde porte atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales
on peut admettre que le meilleur moyen
de lutter contre cette atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales c'est de
renforcer les atteintes aux libertés
fondamentales parce que entre l'état et
les prêts et les personnes privées c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose comme
processus voilà c'était ma troisième
question
je je vais vous demander quelque chose
de ce que j'avais pris un engagement
très ferme pour avoir cette salle qui
est normalement dédiés au rayon groupe
mardi matin parce que c'est la salle qui
nous permettait le film est plus
facilement et cetera que je partirai à
11 heures nous allons partir à 11h10
pour que parce qu il est 11 heures déjà
pour que vous puissiez répondre
clairement pourra pas y avoir de réponse
précise à tout ce que vous avez posé
comme question
je vais demander aux administrateurs et
si vous voulez bien de pouvoir vous
relancez par les écrits ou si vous
pouvez nous faire parvenir et compris
les les
ce que vous avez déjà écrit pour pas que
vous travaillez encore plus là où il
peut y avoir les réponses à un certain
nombre d'interrogations que l'on a pour
que nous avions cherché pour faire notre
rapport et apporter le maximum
d'informations non qu' il ya d'abord des
questions qui ont été posées à mathieu
guidère et à monsieur heisbourg sur
leurs deux points de vue différents
je demande vraiment que vous nous disiez
parce que c'est le débat de la semaine
prochaine pour le projet de loi sera
déposé
concrètement faut-il faire évoluer et
s'il faut faire évoluer sur quoi
précisément notamment et à l'aspect
cybercriminalité il ya l'aspect sur
l'intentionnalité comment peut-on aller
plus loin je
rapidement et eu d'abord une précision
je n'ai pas dit qu'on était en manque de
coordination internationale ou interne
jeudi que la question se pose est ce
qu'il n'est pas voilà ce n'est pas
exactement la même chose sur l'intense
l'intentionnalité et nous sommes déjà en
limite et la loi est incroyablement
généreuse en la matière puisque la
complicité d'une préparation est
suffisante pour pouvoir constituer une
incrimination
autrement dit et si nous n'étions pas
dans un état de droit je considère que
ces dispositions là deviendrait
carrément liberticide nous sommes dans
un état de droit dont on arrive à gérer
à gérer cette disposition aller au delà
me paraîtrait me paraît très fou et sur
le coeur et le spectre que l'on couvre
en matière de terrorisme
madame lienemann a mille fois mille fois
raison d'ailleurs je vais révéler un
petit secret il y avait eu lors de la
rédaction du livre blanc sur le
terrorisme est une discussion assez vive
sur le fait de savoir s'il fallait que
ce soit un livre blanc sur le terrorisme
ou un livre blanc ça la menace
djihadiste et les tenants de cette
deuxième approche avait donné
l'impression de l'emporter et donc je
vais demander à ce qu'il y ait un
arbitrage et au niveau du premier
ministre et des ministres responsables
de cette affaire notamment de miser
intérieur monsieur de villepin d'une
part et monsieur sarkozy de l'autre et
il ya eu une discussion vous me
permettrez de ne pas nommer la personne
que je vais citer peut-être deviné et
mais à un moment donné il y a eu cette
interjection que tout homme ou toute
femme politique reconnaîtra comme étant
extraordinairement raisonnable qui est à
oui on va faire un livre blanc sur le
djihadisme et si demain il ya une secte
genre à oum qui va gaz et les gens dans
le métro moi j'aurais l'air de quoi moi
et est donc on a décidé de faire un
livre blanc sur le terrorisme
et et à laquelle s'était enfin dernier
dernier point et nous sommes dit si
effectivement dans la loi dès tout petit
nombre et monsieur squarcini dans un
entretien au monde au mois de mai de
l'année dernière avait indiqué qu'une
vingtaine de français avaient fait des
stages et au pakistan
on stage genre mais raph si je puis dire
une vingtaine autrement dit ce que vous
recensez ce sont des parcours
strictement individuel si vous voulez
constitué alors si vous voulez
constituer un panel sans rencontrer de
problème de secret parce qu'évidemment
personne ne va dire ah oui c'est
l'ingénieur machin chose qui habite au
numéro temps de la ville de machins et
qui fait partie du panel si cette
personne est sous surveillance et non
pas incriminer mais prenez tout
simplement les personnes qui dont les
affaires sont passés en justice en
france au royaume-uni en allemagne et
vous avez une diversité
on a tout à fait remarquable entrée des
convertis et qui sont comme dirait
monsieur le pen de pure souche
vous avez des born again j'allais dire
j'en ai ras vous avez des des petits
délinquants jean khaled kelkal ou nairas
d'ailleurs et vous avez des diplômés
d'université vous avez des scientifiques
vous avez des ads enfin vous ne pouvez
déduire de ce genre de panels aucune loi
qui s'appliquerait au grand nombre que
l'on peut rencontrer pas on dans les
tribunaux pour enfants
oui je vais être aussi rapide je n'ai
pas parlé d'intention en général j'ai
parlé d' intentions agressives ou
terroristes et je les contextualiser
précisément dans le changement radical
de contexte géopolitique hausse autour
de la méditerranée il me semble qu'il ya
une lutte biologique qui sera enclenchée
en 2011 et que si on n'en prend pas acte
sur le long terme
ce que nous considérons comme banal ou
comme simple comme normal
finir par envahir l'espace démocratique
de liberté et d'égalité sur un certain
nombre de points
cette intention agressive signifie le
passage du fer d'une législation sur le
faire à une législation sur le vouloir
faire cela à une à une vertu
responsabilisante il est évident que
quelqu'un dit je veux tuer quelqu'un
pour moi qu'il le fasse ou non il faut
qu'ils sachent que c'est interdit
on ne peut pas dire je veux détruire la
république on ne peut pas dire je veux
tu es intel ne peut pas dire allant au
jihad
on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut mais ça
au moins une vertu responsabilisante et
didactique pour les individus qui le
fasse alors après que l'on met le degré
de cette responsabilité
c'est le législateur qui verra mais pour
moi si on laisse faire
si on laisse faire ce qui est en train
de se faire je pense qu'on ne protège
pas la personne humaine qui est derrière
on peut prendre des cas précis sur ce
que cela veut dire vouloir faire quelque
chose qui n'a rien à voir avec la faire
mais que le résultat est le même
lorsque vous intimider quelqu'un tous
les jours le résultat c'est comme si
vous avez battu ou ceux comme si vous
l'avez violente et donc je veux bien
m'attarder là dessus j'ai écrit
là-dessus dans les nouveaux terroristes
donc je renvoie à mes travaux sur
l'intense la régressive
pour moi elle est très importante en
tout cas ce que je demandais c'était
uniquement je suis conscient que
l'arsenal juridique est impressionnant
mais il est impressionnant sur le faire
il n'est pas impressionnant sur le
vouloir faire agressif contre les
individus
je voulais une clarification in lever
l'ambiguïté sur la responsabilité dans
ce cas là parce qu'un objectif est de
supprimer la culture de la peur qui
pourrait naître du terrorisme ou du
projet terroriste une démocratie on ne
doit pas avoir peur dans une démocratie
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
enfin très rapidement je suis je il y à
une diversité de profils qui ont été
étudiées il n'existe pas de profil et je
suis férocement opposés aux explications
sociologiques psychologiques
communautariste intégrationniste
assimilationniste de tous
passage à l'acte pourquoi parce que je
distingue la radicalisation de la
violence du passage à l'acte violent
si on explique sociologiquement ou autre
explication psychologique
le passage à l'acte terroriste en
justifie il faut le savoir on le
justifient en le voulions ou non et on
retombe indéfiniment sur les mêmes
justifications des terroristes aux mains
bien je sais ce que je vous frustre
beaucoup si vous d'étape
bon alors je veux je vais je vais dire
un mot jean pierre je vais dire un petit
mot de conclusion
encore une fois vous remercie parce que
je pense que les sujets sont sur la
table après cette première table ronde
les sujets qui vont guider parfois
peut-être de façon plus technique
nos auditions avec des fonctionnaires
avec des juges etc
je crois que ce qui est posée par la
dernière intervention
c'est une réflexion que nous pouvons
avoir peut-être qu'ils sortent du cadre
de la législation strictement
antiterroriste mais qui se rattache
peut-être aussi ou plus à la législation
qui punit l'incitation à la haine à la
etc qui existe dans les lois sur la
presse qui vit en france peut-être qu'il
faut voir comment les moderniser pour
répondre aussi à cela parce que j'ai
bien compris ce que vous dites
en gros on a une législation très très
particulière en france qui permet quand
il y a quand on juge que l'intention de
passer à l'acte et ont été suffisamment
avérées d'arrêter et de punir même ce
qui permet d'être dans la prévention et
pas d'agir à seulement toujours et après
coup bien donc où on a le sentiment
qu'on a cela pour l'acte lui-même
l'intention de l'acte de tuer ou de
l'acte terroriste
par contre je vois bien que nous avons
un problème que vous soulevez qu'à
partir du moment où il y à un phénomène
plus massif de résille r&d aux logiques
où il y a
sur-le-champ l'idéologique sur le par le
net et aussi par
pop up en se cachant parfois derrière
une religion puisque c'est pas la
religion qui est en question qu'on prône
la destruction d'untel ou d'untel à ce
moment là on est relativement
aujourd'hui protégé en tous les cas il
n'y a pas de punition on peut faire
venir un prédicateur qui va dire des
choses tout à fait horrible mais on va
pouvoir punir que celui qui va se saisir
de cela pour justifier un acte
donc nous sommes dans le coeur du sujet
on va vous demander où va chercher
peut-être aussi dans vos travaux
les réponses à un certain nombre de
choses qui ont été dites qui ont été
demandés par les sénateurs auxquels vous
n'avez pas pu répondre
en tous les cas je vous remercie d'avoir
participé à cette à cette table room et
le programme des auditions va continuer
cet après midi
voilà pour cette table ronde organisée
par la commission sénatoriale
d'application des lois sur l'état des
lieux de l'arsenal législatif en matière
de lutte contre le terrorisme pour la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire c'est cet
après midi à 16h30 avec les travaux de
la commission d' enquête sur le coût
réel de l'électricité très belle journée
à tous